con nuestro segundo invitado del día
vamos a hablar de la crisis social y
política que se vive en Perú esto desde
la destitución desde el expresidente
Pedro Castillo porque según la
defensoría del pueblo ya son al menos 49
personas las que han muerto en medio de
estos choques con la policía hoy martes
17 de enero la capital se prepara para
recibir asientos de manifestantes
provenientes del sur de esa nación que
llegarían a Lima para exigir la
renunciar a la presidenta de boluarte
también la clausura de congreso y la
celebración de nuevas elecciones
saludamos entonces a Richard arceles
excongresista independiente y político
peruano Richard gracias por su tiempo
por estar con nosotros en directo
América de Francia 24 y le pregunto
Entonces por este balance que puede
Resaltar desde lo que ha sido la
destitución del expresidente Pedro
Castillo hasta el momento cuando ya
entonces se preparan estos manifestantes
desde el sur del país para llegar a la
capital a hacer de todas estas
exigencias
la presidenta de Dina boluarte
No eso es lo máximo ya no me alcanza el
cable
sí Richard no sé si me estás escuchando
creo que tenías problemas con el audio
lo que le quería preguntar básicamente
era por el balance como usted la
situación de Perú desde la institución
del expresidente Pedro Castillo hasta
ahora cuando la capital se prepara para
recibir a los que apoyan no al
expresidente para pedir la la renuncia
de Dino boluarte
Sí muy buenos días Muchas gracias por la
diferencia definitivamente que es una
situación muy compleja que vive el país
en estas circunstancia son casi tres
semanas de conflictividad pero habría
que entender en contexto qué es lo que
ha sucedido porque en este caso
específico fue que Pedro Castillo
pretendió hacer un golpe de estado al
mismo estilo de Alberto fujimori en 1992
y que en el lapso de cuatro horas él
terminó inclusive ya apresado por
flagrancia por haber intentado irrumpir
en nuestro sistema democrático hay un
sector muy importante que respalda
Castillo eso es innegable y este sector
es el que ha estado actuando sobre todo
en provincias esta situación de
conflictividad que lamentablemente Y eso
sí Hay que condenar nos ha llevado un
espiral de violencia tenemos en este
momento más de cuarenta fallecidos y que
han sido básicamente porque se ha
pretendido tomar infraestructura pública
como expertos no una situación bien
compleja pero que requiere una atención
específica de parte de el gobierno por
sectores porque esto no es una
confrontación entre lima y provincias
como erróneamente sacan varios medios de
Guardián sacó una publicación donde
mencionaba que es la élite limeña contra
con una posición racista contra las
provincias no es tanto así porque
evidentemente chile Lima la gran capital
es una ciudad de migrantes yo diría una
ciudad de provincial
claro Richard y le pregunto Entonces por
qué se concentra este descontento contra
el gobierno que estaba ahorita en Lima
de la presidenta Dina boluarte no porque
se concentra en el sur del país en estas
áreas rurales
sí por una por un tema histórico de
desatención Lamentablemente El Perú ha
crecido sus indicadores macroeconómicos
están a la vanguardia en Latinoamérica
pero objetivamente en las regiones de
provincias tradicionalmente postergadas
y excluidas persisten brechas sociales
de exclusión entonces la elección de
Pedro Castillo generó mucha expectativa
porque se tenía una vez a un presidente
que representaba justamente esos
sectores ahí había un tema identitario
el asunto es que Castillo no ayudó a
reducir estas brechas al contrario se
involucró en actos de corrupción a la
fecha tiene más de 50 carpetas Fiscales
que lo involucran directamente en actos
de corrupción hay dineros de por medio
que se han traficado desde proyectos
ascensos de militares favorecimientos a
los familiares y esto ha generado una
confrontación porque evidentemente había
un cuestionamiento a la corrupción
ejecutivo Pero esto ha sido En
complicidad con el congreso de la
República porque en nuestras leyes en el
Perú El Congreso de la República tiene
mecanismos constitucionales para generar
un equilibrio no interpelaron a los
ministros no censuraron a los ministros
que estaban seriamente cuestionados al
final inclusive avalaron en este momento
también hay varios congresistas
investigados por haber participado en
este tipo de beneficios ilícitos
aprovechándose del cargo público Richard
hablando de lo que ocurrió con las
personas fallecidas en estos choques con
las autoridades
tiene responsabilidad digamos política
la presidenta Dina boluarte sobre estos
hechos a muchos políticos lo digo porque
la acusan digamos de no tomar una acción
contundente y no dar una orden
contundente a las fuerzas del orden para
no disparar munición real en estas
manifestaciones
definitivamente con la cantidad de
Muertos hay una responsabilidad política
eso es innegable y que se tienen que
aperturar las investigaciones ya la
fiscalía de la nación ha procedido con
iniciar un proceso de investigación
porque usted entenderá que los delitos
son individuales se tendrá que
individualizar la responsabilidades pero
también hay varios factores del contexto
no porque es muy importante entender Por
qué se llegó a este nivel de
conflictividad durante 17 meses el
gobierno de Pedro Castillo estuvo
incentivando la confrontación entre
peruanos con discursos de odio con una
estrategia de lucha de clases era
limeños contra provincianos era
inclusive Blancos contra cobrizos
imagínate ese argumento racial en pleno
Siglo 21 después de todo lo que ha
vivido la historia ya de la humanidad y
eso ha generado y ha propiciado
justamente un escenario mayor de
conflictividad ahora también ahí hay
cierta responsabilidad del Estado porque
no ha dotado a las fuerzas policiales
con el equipamiento y necesaria se hace
mucho la comparación en el Perú de los
de las protestas que suceden por ejemplo
en París donde hay inclusive daños
materiales pero no hay ningún muerto en
cambio en el Perú o muerto La diferencia
es que la policía que controla las
protestas en París están bien equipados
Nosotros le decimos acá robocops también
equipados tienen inclusive armas
disuasivas y no letal en el Perú la
policía no cuenta ni siquiera con
indumentaria básica para confrontar una
protesta esta naturaleza